so what you're looking at here is a
function and we're interested in how it
behaves
as you get closer and closer to 3 we
noticed immediately just like in this
case over here because you've got a
denominator there you can't actually
equal 3
you can't just put u equals 3 into an
accent moment so I'm going to write that
down that you that's about three of the
three most ratings the curly brace 3
can't be a value for you okay so
therefore I have to work on this guy up
here
in order to try and get an expression
that I can put u equals C inches okay so
just like before factorization and going
to be the key so I'm going to write the
limit again don't you forget don't
forget tonight I'll do it and what are
these insults what you can do them this
is difference of cubes this is not
YouTube minus three cubes
so therefore the factorization is going
to be now I will point out this is on
your reference sheet is all your
reference sheet
however some poor sorry people didn't
have represented their going to
community so they actually reflect with
each other now um there is also going to
have here like an error on the reference
sheet then tricky thing is the signs one
of a mnemonic that might help you here
into the sides of each er or relate to
the sign you start with C has the widest
an expensive itís so the signs you're
going to get are just remember this I've
told you this before right they're going
to be the same opposite always positive
okay if you're freaked out you like
that's 200 a bar that's what reference
sheet before however I don't appreciate
where it'll do this the other clue of
course with that you've got a you
mentioned another that's the whole point
of doing right so seeing as u minus 3
can't be 0 I can divide the top and
bottom by you mostly okay which leaves
me with this right the limit again okay
here's the whole being here
by the way it's definitely a good idea
to include these brackets because the
limit and your purchase 3 applying to
the whole thing it doesn't just apply to
the U squared and then other stuff it
applies to the entire object of the
entire function okay at this point I've
now simplified to a stage where I can
actually try out uniqua stream when you
get 9 plus 9 plus 5 [ __ ] so what's this
thing going to look like what is it
going to look like well what is this
look like you said 3 u plus 9 these 12
others for AC this thing does not have
any intercepts oh think I'll go take a
clip that's perfect there you into sense
okay so it's going to look something
like this mystery comment I don't know
every time most anyone so I'm just
thinking in my head the axis of symmetry
because remember the axis of symmetry is
minus B on to a right odd the way you
can remember by the way is that it's a
bit at the start of the quadratic
formula right you don't also write the
quadratic form in two pieces because
you're like why would it why would I
because I've got the common denominator
but Riley to Peter's helps you remember
looking at the axis of symmetry so the
axis symmetry in this case will be minus
3 on 2 okay so let's go to one silly
reason my pension yeah nice right there
when you put that in when you get my
chin to over this number the heart um
that as my I before that's wise 9 on -
that's what my under something like that
button but so that's what the problem
looks like but there's a subtle
difference because so whatever that
point is over here somewhere here
there's going to be oh ok
so if I hated just like the products
like psychic cadre does but putting in
this color
means you can take it that you have a
generator function on you so yes your
programs like that you have to put like
X cannot equal 3 like ask the door
anymore kitty just just write 3 that's a
good question what you would probably do
in a case like this you just say see
this is quite as so important right it's
important to weigh an X a Y and assessor
and ekadesha is important
so therefore I'd expect you to actually
label that in 27 okay so you can see how
I can get it close to 27 is I like 4
below or above I just can't get to 27
all right now this is the case when you
can factor out if there's something
obvious here or here now it's easy to
deal with
ok look at question 1 the profession
we're bored let's have a look at say
let's just do 1 1 a pot what they'll do
so you can see on the top of the
question states the limit right so
they're interested in the limit as X
approaches look at infinity and someone
reads the function for week is a big
project where the clinics where yep the
bottom is x squared minus 7x thank you
okay so when you have a look at this you
can see that um it's a bit of a disaster
I suppose you could batrider but I
really want to so cheap in dirty way of
gained through that our problem is to
divide everything through by the highest
power of X let me say that again in
order to go straight to what this limit
is a particulate I'll go to X is equal
to infinity I'll ask you why this is
important in a second and why you can't
always or whatever though you like to do
it X is beneath the point I'm going to
divide every single term there one two
three four five six of them I'm going to
divide all by X square okay watch the
limit as X approaches infinity don't
forget to write ax is equal to that's
going to become divided by x squared
right
what's that gonna become one but this
divided by x squared you've got to get
minus 4x and then trailing on the end
three on x squared let's carry that or
the denominator looks like I've got two
new minus this Plus this now it's a
perfect example of why I try and avoid
saying no to simplify okay because that
does not look simpler than what you
started with but for the purposes of
what we're trying to do is evaluate a
limit it is immensely simpler okay
reprocess you in that if it's X
approaches infinity what happens to
these guys here when X gets really large
they all approach zero don't they like
because you've got I don't care if it's
seven like seven divided by busy still
going first
right so therefore I can say this is
going to be one take away zero plus zero
and that's what they're approaching
divided by 2 take away zero plus zero
right
why do you think it's actually important
to state those zeros because these
things though disappear it's just that
they become so small you can treat them
like as if they were zero so this is a
lot okay as you go ahead and you can
chuck this into Deadhorse and you will
find what are we going to get can
someone help me factorize this
what's that going to be 12 negative 3
negative 4 right
so that we do X minus 2
pretty sure some of you expand that
until we talk about that right so what
are the very weapon choice you're going
to get out of this look x equals 3 on 2
so I said this is a half way
x equals 3 onto you with that here and
what the other if you can see the
sequence together first fine okay I've
got that
the top is easy to factorize that X - -3
minus 1 isn't it it's my 3x minus 3x
minus 1 gross okay and lastly what's the
young what's the y-intercepts when I let
all the x's be 0
you're just going to get 3 over 6 aren't
you well yeah
all cooks it's 1 & 3 1 a drink 1 and 3
and that's better
I think it was dry experiences step
enough and we're in the middle saying
that the y-intercepts was a heart right
which by the way is interesting to me
because I've already got something at ye
being a heart
what's more equal to some the horizontal
asymptote okay so what's the picture
what have I got here I'm going to be
have a look over here I'm going to opt
into this little area right
Whitney's asymptotes like that okay
there's going to be a change in sign
over here so I'm predicting something
like this go go there button and get you
a better one okay and then over here
over here what's going to happen well
you've got to get to this asymptote
don't you these two intercepts tell you
you've got to get from here to here Tana
here's I was a witness before I didn't
have a good example what is going to
happen now what what direction is it
going in is going up isn't it
so clearly it's going to go up a little
bit right but then look we had way to
tell if there's going to be this
horizontal asymptote right so you're
going to have to approach it you can
have to go to you like that
okay